à première vue cette boutique ressemble
à toutes les autres
mais une fois à l'intérieur l'expérience
client elle est nouvelle
tout le processus de paiement se fait en
ligne en utilisant la technologie du
nuage informatique
derrière cette entreprise il y a trois
jeunes de 21 ans le des technologies
similaires existent en europe aux états
unis et beaucoup en asie mais on est les
premiers au canada à faire un check out
qui 100% automatisés première étape le
client doit scanner un code aucune
application ne doit être télécharger au
préalable une fois que les deux mains et
stoning mis dans votre panier virtuel
ça va être une sur devrait pas nier que
vous avez dans une épicerie dans un
magasin et tous avaient besoin de faire
à la fin regardez les iem en tant que
tel et ophélie payer comme support
chirac est tout ce qu'il vous faut c'est
un téléphone intelligent
la carte est confirmée et vous fait
payer directement et vous envoyer la
facture par courriel
si vous avez besoin chaque item est
enregistrée et suivi en temps réel dans
le système si quelqu'un tente de voler
un élément la lame est activée finie la
tente pour payer à la caisse
ici tout se fait en 20 secondes je crois
pas que ça va remplacer les caisses dès
le début ça à prendre 5 10 ans avant que
ça remplace complètement les caisses
mais au moins ça va permettre de
diminuer un peu de plus à plus de deux
caissiers à un caissier et de
repositionner cette personne ment aux
ventes mais on devine pandémie mondiale
période de crise il faut trouver une
nouvelle manière de prix
ça facilite beaucoup l expérience client
s'enlève les fils qui ça rend ton
magasin peu plus efficace clients et
commerçants peuvent venir essayer cette
nouvelle technologie jusqu'au 21 janvier
dans cette boutique éphémère
on n'y pas encore prêt à commercialiser
nos technologies c'est pour ça qu'on
nous la boutique
si pour vraiment finaliser et finir tout
ce qu'on veut faire avec notre but est
vraiment de commencer la virage
numérique et d'initier les commerçants à
la technologie de paiement sans contact
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal